on this sunday night
one million cases in canada and counting
the crisis we're still facing and the
human cost
it's not cases it's people plus a
lottery for leftover vaccine doses
is it ethical players testing positive
the canadian nhl team sidelined by
covid19
major league baseball takes a stand on
election reform
in the state of georgia and the moving
memorial to lives lost
in this pandemic it's like a nightmare
i'm hoping to wake up from still
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us the fight against the kova 19
pandemic in this country
is not going the way we hoped case
numbers are spiking
yet again yesterday canada crossed the
one million mark for confirmed kova 19
cases a year ago that was the number of
people infected
worldwide back in april 2020 the idea of
receiving a vaccine seemed a long way
off
as of today more than five and a half
million canadians have received at least
one dose
that's 14.7 percent of the population
but it's the variance fueling this
latest surge of infections
that have medical professionals worried
and as abigail beeman reports
it's an extra challenge with such a low
percentage of the population
protected here's your chocolate
and your egg chocolate on a chair no
direct handoff for an easter sunday that
looks so different
a second year in a row families can
safely drive around town
mask up come pick up their easter egg
canada hit a grim holiday weekend
milestone one
million coveted 19 cases it's people
for me a million people is a lot of
people
but more importantly it's a rapidly
increasing number in the wrong groups of
people who don't have access to enough
services in canada
cases are climbing in several provinces
spurned by variants
potentially the busiest they've been in
15 years after a drop in covid 19
hospital admissions in bc dr gerald
derosa is now seeing them climb
one of the bigger concerns i think is
with some of these variants that
we are seeing younger people getting
quite a bit sicker
and requiring a lot of critical care
support more younger people in hospital
in part because older canadians are more
likely to be vaccinated and protected
and because there are simply more people
getting sick with variants that are more
easily transmissible
one bc researcher estimates variants
account for half of all new cases
alberta says it's 35 percent of cases
there
and it's investigating one quote
significant outbreak
the situation that we're living right
now in terms of
variance is different from the one that
we had last year
these variants are much more highly
transmittable and they're more prone for
you to get
severe symptoms the icus never really
decompressed from
the second wave unfortunately and and
icu capacity
certainly remains a major issue dr isaac
bogash is working on the covid ward this
long weekend
he says they're getting more admissions
but across ontario
icu's are the real problem if we carry
on in this trajectory
ward beds will also be a problem as well
dr bogar says the million case marker
presents an opportunity to think about
how we can make things better going
forward here in ontario there's a real
push to vaccinate vulnerable essential
workers faster
and better support people who can't work
from home
abigail beeman global news ottawa
many canadians are still waiting to get
the vaccine but in some parts of the
country
there are lotteries to get doses that
would otherwise go unused
that's led to an ethical debate as
catherine ward explains
experts believe these efforts not to
waste a drop
once again underscore the disparities in
this pandemic
we're going to draw five names because
we're going to have less than five
vaccines waiting in the cold saturday a
crowd
gathered at a vaccine clinic in north
toronto hoping their name would be
called for a chance at a leftover dose
of a covid19 vaccine first name
the person who sent this video to global
news did not want to be identified for
privacy reasons
but says they were allowed to put their
name in this lottery even though they
are not yet
eligible we reached out to the clinic
for comment but did not hear back
by deadline reasons for leftover doses
vary which include unfilled or canceled
appointments
in a statement ontario's ministry of
health says public health units and
vaccination clinics have been directed
to put in place
processes to fill last-minute
cancellations and end-of-day doses with
people who
are identified as priority populations
susan larue knows what it's like to win
the vaccine lottery
she stopped by a pharmacy in vancouver
to get on a wait list
but because she qualified by age larue
left with that much sought after
shot in the arm he said to me well
actually we had a no-show so you can get
it now
so i was like what now some experts say
making sure
priority groups getting vaccinated first
is key
but at the same time suggesting no doses
should be wasted
even if it means some people get the
shot before they are eligible
you can't have unfilled spots fill the
spots and if people are you know 18 and
up
i have no problem with anyone getting
vaccinated if there's unfilled spots
vaccines aren't going to expire by the
way
the you know pfizer vaccine can sit for
about five days in a refrigerator once
it's been thawed
moderna can sit for a month like the
vaccines aren't going to go to waste
but the spaces are going to go to waste
and there's no reason for that to happen
other doctors say relying on lotteries
to ensure all doses are used
means luck won't necessarily prevail for
those most at risk
we have to recognize that this is not an
equal opportunity virus when we pull
a name out of a hat in terms of who gets
the covid19 vaccine
it can mean that people are left out i
think that there has to be
a more effective way to make sure that
extra doses are going to those who need
it
currently there is no national strategy
on what to do with leftover coveted
vaccine doses
such policies are up to provincial and
local authorities
robin catherine ward in toronto thanks
catherine
let's take some time here to show you
the trajectory of the pandemic in large
part due to the swift and vicious
variants
as of april 1st there have been more
than 11 000 confirmed cases of variants
of concern
the majority of these more than 10 000
cases
involve the b117 variant that emerged in
the uk
the p1 variant associated with brazil is
also taking hold in some provinces
with nearly 500 cases nationally
in saskatchewan where there have been
more than 2200 infections linked to
variants of concern
parts of the province are once again in
lockdown
nathaniel dove reports she's probably
sticking me phoning i'm phoning a phone
eight times a day
this easter all sheena nult is able to
do is call her relatives
it's scary that they could get sick
but it's also terrifying that they have
to deal with everything alone
the kofit 19 pandemic is keeping her
close family apart
it's been hard on her mom normal doesn't
come and
lock you back down and get scared again
of the new variant that's coming
so we were scared before and was even
more scared now
and her best friend who's more of a
sister she doesn't even
know my new stepson she doesn't know my
new boyfriend she doesn't
know their personalities at all or what
our dynamic is like
they're all in different cities in
saskatchewan and experiencing different
stages of the third wave
jesse boss lives in regina which is
locked down
the city accounts for the vast majority
of cases caused by the variance of
concern
mostly the more contagious b-117
tammy nalt is in moosejaw which is close
behind the queen city
but isn't under lockdown yet saskatoon
has just a fraction of the cases regina
does
but a public health professor at the
university of saskatchewan is warning
that won't last the big issue with the
two cities is
time right now
it's it's like looking into the future
epidemiologist corey newdorf says
saskatoon needs to prepare for the worst
hospitalizations in the province are
trending up and a record number of
people are in intensive care units
nudorf says the variants are the cause
and knowing when to clamp down again
is the strongest defense give an inch
and we're going to take a mile
on this i think it's going to be here
it's just a matter of time when so
i'm not scared i'm anxious sheena nalt
says knowing what's coming
doesn't make it any easier she's worried
about her family
and every phone call is bittersweet love
you
i love you too nathaniel dove global
news saskatoon
the vancouver canucks are an example of
how quickly the variant first identified
in brazil
can attack 20 players and coaches have
tested positive for kova 19 and
several of those cases are the more
contagious p1 variant
the virus has spread through the team
despite strict safety protocols put in
place by the league
like daily testing the nhl is proceeding
on the assumption that the entire
team will likely test positive some of
the canucks are reportedly
very ill with symptoms that include
vomiting cramping
and dehydration and some of their family
members
have already tested positive
in the u.s major league baseball is
taking a stand on voter rights
the league decided to pull its all-star
game out of atlanta because of the
state's controversial election bill
opponents argue the new law will hurt
minorities the most
but as jennifer johnson reports
georgia's governor has come out
swinging atlanta has struck out after
major league baseball pulled its july
all-star game out of the city
the mlb made the decision in protest of
georgia's new restrictive voting law
requiring new ids for mail-in ballots
limiting ballot drop-off boxes
and making it illegal for anyone except
poll workers to offer food or water to
voters waiting in lines
major league baseball cave to fear and
lies from
liberal activists they ignored the facts
of our new election
integrity law and they ignored the
consequences of their decision
on our local community georgia's
governor says he's not backing down even
as americans take to social media
calling on consumers to boycott delta
airlines in coca-cola
two big-name georgia-based corporations
nearly 200 companies across the country
have condemned the new law
the mlb's decision will cost the state
an estimated 100 million
in tourism dollars while i certainly am
disappointed that major league baseball
has decided to pull the all-star game
from cobb county georgia
i certainly do understand
georgia voters are protesting the
restrictions saying they specifically
target black voters
who turned out in record numbers in the
2020 election
dozens of other state legislatures are
considering similar bills
which democrats say are all aimed at
suppressing minority voters
it's just another way to keep us from
turning our vote in the republican back
bill passed after former president
donald trump
repeated baseless claims of widespread
voter fraud in georgia
which kemp and other election officials
disputed he said
there were no issues and others in
charge said there were no issues so why
then are you changing the rules
already a number of lawsuits have been
filed to try and overturn the new law
and president joe biden has asked the
u.s justice department
to investigate just how legal it is
jennifer johnson global news washington
three canadians are up for an ncaa
basketball title at this year's march
madness championships
the trophy is a guarantee in the women's
final with toronto's alyssa jerome
playing for stanford
taking on shayna pellington of pickering
ontario who plays for arizona
and tomorrow canada's hopes are on
aurora ontario's
andrew nemphard to steal the show in the
men's final between
gonzaga and baylor now if the stars are
all aligned
it will be the first time in the
tournament's history that a canadian has
won both the men's
and women's titles in the same year
a part of florida is under a state of
emergency tonight because a wastewater
reservoir is on the verge of collapse
and could trigger
a major ecological disaster hundreds of
residents in the tampa bay area have
been forced to flee their homes
immediately there are fears upon holding
back hundreds of millions of liters of
radioactive wastewater
could breach at any moment and if it
does a toxic torrent could come rushing
into the neighborhoods below florida's
governor plans to go after those
responsible for the situation
administration is dedicated to full
enforcement of any damages to our
state's resources
and holding the company hrk accountable
for this event
this is not acceptable it's not
something we will allow to persist
just over a week ago a leak was
discovered in one of the walls of the
77-acre reservoir which contains
leftover from the production of
fertilizer
coming up the case for covet-compliant
courtrooms
and the royal rumble within jordan's
longest ruling family
the pandemic has slowed the wheels of
criminal justice in canada
prosecutors say it's been difficult
getting cases to trial
especially jury trials they require more
space than many courtrooms allow
but as ross lord explains the court
system is taking measures
to adopt for those working in the court
system
two new courtrooms in nova scotia are a
welcome site
the first ever in atlanta canada to be
designed for physical distancing
they're larger than older courtrooms
which means they can hold jury trials
while respecting covet 19 rules it's
been a year
since we had some in halifax our biggest
jurisdiction
and you'll see across the country a lot
of jurisdictions are struggling to have
jury trials
they're also struggling to administer
justice the pandemic has forced to shift
to virtual or telephone court sessions
some lawyers who do appear in person
are nervous in a letter to provincial
justice officials obtained by global
news
the union for federal prosecutors says
it's received
troubling reports of inconsistent
approaches to health and safety
by some courts tribunals and judicial
officers
but cova-compliant courtrooms could also
prevent another big problem
cases being thrown out of court over
long delays in bringing an accused to
trial
something that's happened many hundreds
of times across canada
since the supreme court's jordan
decision in 2016
including accused killers some cases are
in jordan
uh you know jordan danger meaning that
they're over the 30 months for supreme
court and over 18 months for
provincial court so there are there are
some dangers there the jordan decision
does allow lengthy delays in
exceptional circumstances out of the
crown's control
the federal government has promised to
clarify with legislation if necessary
to confirm the pandemic is legally
exceptional
in the meantime governments and the
judiciary are exploring more ways
to keep the wheels of justice moving
ross lord
global news still ahead the royal
rivalry in a middle east country
key to western allies
you're watching global national
at least 11 people are dead after a
truck collided with a passenger bus in
china
the crash happened on a major highway in
the eastern part of the country
initial reports suggest the truck veered
into the path of the oncoming bus
two other trucks rolled over when they
swerved to avoid that wreck
more than a dozen people were injured in
taiwan crews removed the crumpled
carriages of an express train from the
tunnel where it derailed on friday
the death toll from the disaster has
been revised to 48
from 51. nearly 200 people were injured
in the crash
it was caused by a truck rolling onto
the tracks investigators say the truck's
emergency brake
was not engaged the driver has since
apologized and says he will cooperate
with the investigation the former crown
prince of jordan has been placed under
house arrest
prince hamza bin hussein the
half-brother of king abdullah
is one of almost 20 people arrested in
the kingdom the prince is accused of
taking part in a plot to destabilize the
country with foreign support
public clashes within the kingdom's
long-ruling family
are rare accusations of prince hamza for
sure this is something new
never happened before usually problems
within the royal family
are kept there inside within the royal
family
i think if there's a mistake that
it should be solved within the family
and it's important for the royal family
to be always
united the prince denies any wrongdoing
he claims he's being punished for
speaking out against corruption
the unprecedented move has raised
concern about stability in the country
that is seen as a key western ally in
the middle east
in his annual easter message to the
world the pope denounced the armed
conflicts that are still
taking place during a pandemic as
scandalous
francis says there is still too much
violence in the world
while many people suffer the pandemic's
social and economic pressures
he urged countries to expedite global
vaccination efforts
and not to forget the poorer nations who
need help
on the inoculation front
on this easter weekend buckingham palace
released photos of the queen and prince
charles getting some
fresh air while going for a stroll at
frogmore house
the queen usually takes a walk to st
george's chapel for easter services
but this year was a private service with
those closest to her
up next remembering the victims of the
virus at london's
wall of hearts
the united kingdom may be one of the
leading countries in vaccination efforts
but that doesn't change the fact it's
also had one of the worst death tolls in
this pandemic
now some families in britain have
created a moving memorial to honor the
loved ones they've lost to the virus
and as redmond shannon reports the
location
is a political statement
a simple pink heart repeated
over and over and over almost
150 thousand times stretching
hundreds of meters along this wall
one heart for every person in the uk
whose death certificate
mentioned covid19 among the volunteers
painting hearts
is sophie rawlings i came here today
because sadly lost both parents in
january
seven days apart unreal and shocking
it's
like a nightmare i'm hoping to wake up
from still
so when i see this was going on i
thought they deserved to be part of the
wall they deserve to be remembered like
all these other people
the campaign group behind the national
covered memorial wall
didn't ask for permission from the
borough council
but they have received its blessing
they're not numbers
they're all names and they're all people
and they've all got someone like me
devastated on the other end
the location of the memorial is
significant it sits directly opposite
the houses of parliament
and the wall itself backs on to the
hospital where prime minister boris
johnson was treated
in intensive care for coward 19. the
group
doesn't just want to break the
conscience of the government
we're kind of been asking for an inquiry
so you can understand
what happened how we've ended up where
we are and how we've lost all these
lives
and just kind of understand why we have
so many hearts to draw
but just drawing these hearts has made
one difference
it's the least i've cried in three
months i was just saying to my friend i
cry every day all day
but coming here painting these arts i
don't know why it's just made me feel
i don't know nice the group says it will
remove the hearts
when asked the british government plans
a permanent memorial
after the pandemic redmond shannon
global news
london what a nice story redmond
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is mile zero of the
great trail in victoria bc
we'd love to see your corner of the
country so please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i hope to see
you back here tomorrow have a great
night
you